>> Tucker: IT'S NOT AN
OVERSTATEMENT TO SAY THE LESS
ATTACK ON AMERICA'S BORDER
SECURITY HAS SUDDENLY BECOME AN
ATTACK ON AMERICA ITSELF.
ON FRIDAY AT I.C.E.'S FACILITY
IN AURORA, COLORADO.
HUNDRED EXTREMISTS FROM THE
GROUND PULLED ON AN AMERICAN
FLAG AND TRY TO BURN UP YOUR DAY
AND THEY SENT A MEXICAN FLAG OF
THE FLYABLE TO TRY TO REPLACE
IT.
THIS WAS AWFUL AND DEEPLY
REVEALING OF THE MOTIVES BUT
WHAT HAPPENED ON SATURDAY IN
WASHINGTON STATE WAS EVEN WORSE
THAN THAT.
VILLAIN VONS BRONSON, HE WAS
BLANKED AT THE HANDS CHIEF OF
DOMESTIC TERRORIST MOVEMENT,
CHECKED IN ICE FACILITY IN
TACOMA.
HE TOURED SEVERAL CARS THAT
APPARENTLY HELP TO FRIENDS
FACILITY TO THE GROUND.
HE WAS SHOT DEAD BEFORE HE COULD
KILL ANYONE.
ONLINE, MEMBERS CELEBRATED
THERE.
FACEBOOK THEN, ALEX JONES, A
HATEMONGER, FACEBOOK HAS NO
PROBLEM POSTING, INCLUDING THIS
SEATTLE ANTIFASCIST ACTION
BRANDED FOR TiVo.
ON FACEBOOK, QUOTE POST TO THIS
CALL, WHEN ARE GOOD FAN AND
COMRADE PHILIP VONS BRONSON TOOK
ACTION AT THE DETENTION CENTER
AND SUIT SICK TACOMA, HE BECAME
A MONGER AGAINST FASCISM.
TODAY WE SOUP POURED ANOTHER
MARTYR AGAINST FASCISM, MAY HIS
DEATH SUPPORT STAND AGAINST --
THEY WANT TO BANG, BY THE WAY,
THEN SPONSORED MAY HAVE FAILED
BUT OTHERS SHOULD IMITATE HIM IN
LAUNCHING MORE TERROR ATTACKS ON
AMERICAN SOIL.
THAT'S WHAT THEY'RE SAYING.
FACEBOOK DOESN'T HAVE A PROBLEM
WITH THAT, OF COURSE.
WELCOME YOU THINK ALL OF THIS
WOULD SPARK SOME CONCERN HERE
LIBERALS MARTEL IS THAT IT'S
TIME FOR A NATIONAL
CONVERSATION.
MAYBE GUN CONTROL.
NO.
IT HAS THE IMPLICIT SUPPORT OF
THE RESPECTABLE LEFT.
SO FAR, NOT A SINGLE CANDIDATE
HAS CONDEMNED SATURDAY'S ATTACK.
IT'S HORRIBLE TO BELIEVE THAT
STILL APPEARED WE HOPE WE ARE
WRONG HERE IT MAY BE THEY WILL
CONDEMN THEM DURING THIS TRIAL
BUT AS OF RIGHT NOW, WE BELIEVE,
THAT NOT A SINGLE DEMOCRAT
RUNNING FOR THE NOMINATION HAS
CONDEMNED A TERROR ATTACK THAT
TOOK PLACE ON OUR SOIL YESTERDA
YESTERDAY.
SATURDAY.
BUT WHY WOULD THEY CONDEMN IT?
THEY ARE ON BOARD WITH IT.
JUST A FEW WEEKS AGO,
"THE NEW YORK TIMES" PUBLISHED
AN OP-ED CALLING I.C.E. AGENTS
COMPLICIT," MASSIVE CONTRAST
TODAY AND CALLED FOR I.C.E.
AGENTS TO HAVE THEIR NAMES AND
HOME ADDRESSES PUBLICIZED.
SO WHY SHOULD WE FEEL BAD FOR
PEOPLE WHO ARE TRYING TO MURDER
I.C.E. AGENTS?
PAUSE FOR A SECOND AND JUST LET
THE ABSURDITY IN.
ALL LABOR COLONISTS TO 14 VOTE.
THAT'S HOW INSANE THIS MOMENT IS
THAT WE ARE LIVING.
ANYWAY, THE LABOR ECONOMIST
DESCRIBES THE TERRORIST ATTACK
AS QUOTE, RIGHTEOUS SABOTAGE.
SHE COMPARED HIM TO PARTISANS
FIGHTING AGAINST THE AND THEN
CALLED FOR MORE TERROR ATTACKS.
QUOTE, "AS VINCE BRONSON AND
MANY OF THE OTHER HORRID
COMMENTS BEFORE HIM IS MADE
CLEAR, THERE ARE MANY WAYS TO
FIGHT BACK AGAINST A VIOLENT
FASCIST REGIME.
PERHAPS IT'S TIME FOR MORE OF US
TO PUT OUR THINKING CAPS ON."
THE DECADENT RICH ARE REALLY
UNBELIEVABLE AND OF COURSE,
KEVIN KELLY IS ONE OF THEM.
SO IS ANTIFA.
THESE ARE THE MOST PRIVILEGED
PEOPLE IN OUR SOCIETY.
OF COURSE, THIS ISN'T THE
WORKING CLASS RISING OUT.
THIS IS THE RULING CLASS
PUNCHING DOWN.
WHEN KIM KELLY, BY THE WAY, IT
ISN'T LETTING OFF THE LABOR
MOVEMENT FOR TEENAGE GIRLS, SHE
IS ALSO A CONTRIBUTOR AT NPR.
YOU CAN MAKE THIS UP.
IN OTHER WORDS, GOVERNMENT
FUNDED NEWS OUTLETS ARE DIRECTLY
SPREADING THE MESSAGE OF PEOPLE
WHO PROMOTE THE MURDER OF
GOVERNMENT OFFICIALS.
IT'S SICK.
THIS COUNTRY'S LAWS CANNOT